okay perfect so thanks for having me
here and so I've given several talks
with this talk is like a first of many
kinds and I thought I should just point
it out I never had big an audience
wearing of my talks so so this is one of
the biggest audiences I've ever had and
I've also not given many programming
talks as my second programming talk but
I think the most important part of how
the stocks is very different is the
first talk that I have rehearsed in
front of the Customs and Border Patrol
so so I took the bus from Montreal
yesterday and so late in the night and
so they asked me a question okay so why
are traveling to New York usually my
answer is ok I'm going here to see a
friend but this time around I said you
know what let me let me just tell them
I'm giving a talk so so then they probed
a little bit further and I said they
were really confused that why is an
operations management professor from a
Canadian university giving a talk to a
bunch of hackers data hackers in New
York at Newton the company that deals
with predictive learning analytics right
I mean nothing really fit so I spent
like a good half an hour trying to
explain to the the guy who actually was
pretty pretty good I try to explain to
him what interactive documents are how
does it fit in with what I do so so it
was it was actually a very very good
rehearsal so on that note let me get
started with with today's with a today's
talk so I'm going to be talking about
interactive documents now before we we
kind of move on I just want to kind of
quickly give your perspective of what
interactive document is I mean it's
something that everybody knows about it
is experienced an interactive document
is essentially any document that allows
the user the end user that in one or
more ways okay now in my mind one of the
best examples of an interactive document
is
visualization of the fight well paths to
the White House now unfortunately I was
not able to embed it in the slide deck
because for some reason all these Gras
all these interactive visualizations
don't fit well as I frames so I've just
chosen to do a screenshot so this is a
terrific example of an interactive
document okay another example which
actually I just picked up today there
was this nice visualization of Airbnb
versus hotels the price comparison this
is again just a screenshot this article
talks a lot about it really allows you
to kind of play around with the data see
what's happening okay now these two are
interactive visualizations not one of my
favorite examples this is actually a
screenshot from Khan Academy and for
those of you have tried Khan Academy out
it's a nut it's a nice little tool where
students can practice concepts that
they've learned so as opposed to just
giving a static PDF where you can do
limited stuff this setup allows them to
really interact they can ask for hints
they can check their answer so it makes
the experience a lot better okay so
clearly interactive documents are
superior static documents from a user
perspective but why don't we see a lot
of interactive documents being created I
thought about it and I think the answer
to the question is there are not too
many tools that help create such
documents easily okay and my my
motivation to all this actually came
from I teach statistics at McGill and I
was very frustrated with all the tools
that existed I couldn't embed content I
couldn't embed videos I couldn't embed
interactive content and so that's how I
got started in this soup today today's
talk is going to be focused on how to
make it easy to create style and share
interactive presentations interactive
documents from our okay I have a
question to do some of you so how many
of you have heard the the concept of a
dynamic document okay so a dynamic
document is essentially a document
they're the source okay can dynamically
generate output so essentially think
about think about a report that you
write with a whole bunch of tables and
figures a dynamic document is one where
if the underlying data changes you can
essentially run the document execute it
and you'll be able to produce the
required required output okay so my talk
is also going to be about dynamic
documents and dynamic documents and
interactive documents are actually
independent of each other so my talk is
going to be a dynamic interactive
documents so let me go over how I've
organized my talks i'm going to give you
an overview of dynamic documents then i
will move on to creating documents for
the web using some of the tools that
that there and some of the tools that i
created the third point here is about
injecting interactivity so i will talk a
little bit about various kinds of
interactivity that can be injected into
a document and time permitting and it
can all just show you a couple of demos
which which would kind of bring things
to life then I'm going to talk a little
bit about interactive visualizations
it's a big topic by itself but I'll kind
of depending on the time I have I'll
cover some aspects of it and finally I
will talk about a couple of examples and
case studies one of which would be the
the city bike visualization that I built
using some of the tools i created and
that's essentially going to be talking
and agile asked me how long I can go on
so I can go on as long as you want so if
people seem a little disinterested in
just feel free to tell me so that I
could wrap things up quickly okay but
important thing if you have questions I
prefer to take questions as I I do the
talk because there are a lot of topics
being covered so it's going to be very
hard to kind of go back to it at the end
so feel free to ask me questions I'll
scale back what I'm covering in the talk
based upon time okay so more questions
the bed okay so let's kind of go over
dynamic documents as I described before
dynamic documents is
not a concept that's new it's been
around for a long time sometimes it's
called literate programming some people
call it reproducible research although
there are subtle differences between
these at the end of the day a dynamic
document is an ordered composition of
text and core chunks I'm using this
definition from a paper by gentleman and
lang and the idea is that a dynamic
document can be executed to produce the
output and as underlying data changes
the entire document changes okay now a
dynamic document is dynamic only from
the author's perspective it is not
dynamic from the end users perspective
because they may be interactivity they
may not be interactivity so I want to
point out a distinction between dynamic
and interactive now gentlemen and land
in their paper they extend the concept
of dynamic documents by describing an
idea which I honestly I didn't start
with this but as an academic we always
kind of like to go back and see what's
been done and I realized this actually
is what I'm doing they introduced the
concept of a compendium the idea is
actually pretty simple idea is that you
can think of a dynamic document along
with a bunch of data and auxiliary
libraries which together constitute a
compendium and you can then use what are
called transformers to transform the
compendium into different views okay and
you could basically have a code view you
could have a PDF view you could have a
web view okay now there are multiple
tools that do all this and if you're if
it in the world of are you would be
familiar with s leave and knitter which
is one of the later tools in this in
this area if you come from a pipe on
background that is deck see there is
ipython notebooks that is Fink's and and
pretty much every language has its own
set of tools okay now my focus is going
to be on just one of these views okay
I'm going to be focusing on the web view
because i believe the webview is the one
where you can inject a lot of
interactivity web browsers have made
great progress
in terms of what they can do so i am
going to be focusing exclusively on the
web based views and within the web based
views i'm going to show you time
permitting i'm going to show you how you
can create slides articles websites
dashboards all with a simple set of
tools right now in our but the the
design of the entire the architecture
and the design of the entire system is
language agnostic so pretty much every
to live pig can be implemented in Ruby
Python or any of any scripting language
okay so let me let me get started in
showing you a couple of a couple of
things about creating documents for the
web I'm going to try to do this with the
way the mic on here so let's try to
okay I'm just going to increase the font
size so that you can see it
is that is that visible to people at the
back okay so so here is an example of of
a document ok and I'm going to show you
how this document can be converted into
something that can be used on the web
okay so this is actually it's what's
called an R markdown document and there
are three parts to the document on the
top you essentially have yeah Mel front
matter how many of you here have used
Jekyll or develop or aware of jiggle
okay so Jekyll is a blogging platform
but the top section of it is essentially
yeah Mel I'll come I'll come talk about
it and what you see below is essentially
the its marked down mixed with our core
chunks okay now let me show you a couple
of things and if you use our studio in
why you would be familiar with a few a
few of these so first I'm going to I'm
going to see if I have slide if I loaded
just to make sure that i want to start
without that actually okay so let me
attach slide if I oops package
I'm gonna be a little slow because with
the mic I have only one hand left to
type ok so the need to HTML thing that
you see here essentially converts it
into into a into a web-based document
the Saudis light deck is yet so I'll
kind of show you how you can make into a
slide deck so what I'm going to be doing
now is I'm going to be using what i call
a framework a framework essentially is a
set of JavaScript CSS layouts and
essentially acids that help slide that
helped style the content that you see
here ok so I'm going to start out with
one of my favorite frameworks which is
which is what I belt which is what I
built this presentation with and I'm
just going to make a couple of changes
here i will describe those changes to
you
so let me let me press the net HTML
button and you will see so you will see
that the same the same document is now
transformed into a slide deck okay so so
the whole idea is that you want to keep
content at least I want to keep content
and the the view separate from each
other because once you do that the
advantage that you can essentially style
your documents any which way that you
want ok I'll show you a couple more
couple more examples before before I
move on to the next part of my talk so
if you want to convert the same slide
deck into into reveal jas which is not a
really popular framework so I'm going to
do the bjs now reveal JS accepts a few
other arguments so I'm going to
essentially do theme and I'm going to
choose the Solarize theme that are like
okay and yeah I'm going to leave it at
that ok so now let's do this so you see
this is exactly the same content but you
essentially get a completely different
look ok so so the advantage the
advantage of this approach is separating
view from the view from the content is
that you can essentially you separating
the two processes and you can
essentially focus on the document
creation part of it ok I'll show you one
other example which I I think I really
like and then I will move on to the next
next part so one of the frameworks which
I implemented is impress j/s how many of
you have have seen in place yeah so it's
basically a Prezi like framework and of
course I I would never use this in a in
a serious presentation because it's kind
of nauseating as you can see but
essentially this presentation was also
created using a similar set of our mark
down tools and I mean so you can you can
see why
why you wouldn't use it in a in a
serious presentation but i think that
the fire i wanted i hope is that you can
separate two views and that essentially
gives you a lot of other in terms of
what you can do with dynamic documents
okay so let me switch back to my slide
deck and i'll explain a few things so
now how is this guy how is made possible
right what what is the reason that this
structure works and i just are a spin a
little bit of time of the architectural
i define and I'll show you why you can
kind of extend this to multiple contexts
so essentially slide if I at the very
first step it converts are more down in
to mark down using knitter okay so and
for those of you not familiar with
better it'll essentially combines the
core chums in the text and essentially
execute them and push them together in a
single drop okay so the marginal
document is what I work with now the
next step is actually a paradigm which
has been popularized a lot by a happy
victim and I think it's a really cool
framework a split apply combine and
that's exactly how sly defy works okay
so split applying combined so the first
stage i sent a split by markdown
document into a slides second step I
apply a bunch of transformations on and
then finally you combine them and make
it up into up HTML Dom okay so this is
the split stage this is the apply stage
and you will see the apply stage
essentially there's a parson render I'll
come and automatic this little later and
finally combined and you have a HTML
it's like okay no one of the biggest
problems with HTML slides that people
leave a doc r is the lack of ability to
style HTML flights easy both in terms of
layout and in terms of various various
other styling
related issues okay so they go back to
the slide deck here and i'll switch back
to the google same up so that's the line
using okay so so what I'm going to be
doing now is I am going to be using a
okay a veteran essentially allows
we can extend the functionality of a
slide thing and this is the beginning of
interactivity so I'm gonna essentially
inject interactivity in the form of with
okay so a quiz question and I'm going to
create a creative here and I hope you
can just ask I hope it works so oh so
this is going to be my quiz so it's a
very simple question what is one plus
one
four choices one two three and
I'm going to add a hit and I'm also
going to add an explanation so the hand
is just going to be this is a hint this
is just so that you can see where
chilled up on the screen and this isn't
and now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to use a concept and solidify that
is called a layout or a template and the
ants symbol essentially tells sly defile
if this slide should be this light
should essentially be rendered in a
slightly different way okay and the
layout I want to use is a radio way out
what the radially out tells fight fires
will get this slide essentially
converted into a radio button based quiz
question ok and I'm going to bark the
answer which is two and i'm just going
to market nothing emphasis ok so this
pretty much looks like this is plain
text right this is plain text there is
nothing sophisticated about it and now
i'm going to go ahead and hopefully it
should give me what I want
so there you go so here it converted it
into a quiz question okay with a nice
set of buttons which a style by twitter
bootstrap now if you press an answer and
you get the submit button saying you're
wrong you can put the to subweb just you
try if you ask for showing the answer
it's basically giving you this is an
explanation which is what we load okay
and if I ask for the hand it's basically
showing me that this is a okay so this
is the first example of interactivity
okay and I actually use this with mine
stands classes so essentially i give my
students a bunch of questions they can
interactively use it use it with lessons
and the reason this is possible is
because as I said the arm bar down
essentially goes through a bunch of
transformations which converts it into
the HTML required for you Chris okay now
I can't take you in the amount of time
available i might take you through the
entire process of how the this
particular layout works but i want to
give you an idea about how i mean
overall this slide transformation
process takes place and then I think
these things together and there's more
documentation available on the website
if you have any questions please feel
free to stop and ask okay
so I'm going to be talking so the
journey of the slide so what happens to
this michael i showed you this is this
particular graphic wait i said slide is
what we parsed and then rent it okay and
this is actually the step that gives
clarify the power okay i'll get you do a
simple slide so this is a very simple
slide as you can see there is there is
some markup on the first line along with
the three dashes and then there is a
slight title and the context for the
slide okay so the first step the first
step in in in sonification this slide is
essentially parsed and it's converted
into a payload okay and especially the
payload as you can see the title is
isolated the content gets isolated there
are a bunch of other properties the ID
the background and similarly you have
the header okay and once it gets first
its then it's actually combined with a
layout okay so layout is where the HTML
comes in okay and that's the reason why
as I said you can keep content separate
from the from the actual view so for
example this is the default layout that
comes with sliding fine with the google
io 2012 framework it's essentially a
mustache template and you're not
familiar with mustache it's actually a
very simple logic list ventilating
framework and all that you need to know
is that if you look at any of the
quantities inside the braces okay those
are like placeholders okay so where you
see slide dot class that will get
substituted with the class of the slide
in this case there is no class but if
they were a class then it's going to get
substituted similarly the slide dot
header gets up student with the header
off v slide okay now once that happens
the next step is to combine the payload
and the layout and render it as an
output and so once that happens this is
basically
ml that gets generated and in the view
it's going to essentially look like this
ok so this approach is actually allows
you to tease apart to set essentially
what is happening with the quiz reject
that you saw ok the quiz reject was
essentially once the slide was sparse it
was taken through a layout which already
had the buttons built in and I had
already programmed the javascript
required for those behavioral things ok
so i just had another slide kind of show
the same thing so i'm going to talk more
about interactivity ok so you saw one
form of interactivity which is
essentially converting everything the
javascript and letting javascript do all
the interactive part ok so there is no r
is not really involved once the document
is ready ok but you can do a lot of cool
things with with our especially now that
there is there is shiny which allows
it's an r package that allows you to run
our in the server ok so i'm going to
show you a couple of examples of
interactivity that are injected using
some of which are injected using shine
ok I'll first show you the demo and then
I'm going to go to go over the code
so this is something that you've already
seen the next kind of interactivity that
that's kind of has already built in this
line falsh I'll show you the the markup
required to create this particular slide
so this this text box that you see here
some female be able to see the code find
this long but essentially it allows you
to embed our code in an interactive form
so this is actually something that i can
actually i can run the code and i could
create a ggplot2 graph life okay so
right now this is wild up too shiny
which means that it will work only
offline but I have another version which
is wild up to open cpu which means that
you can actually use these kind of
slides online so let's say you have an
hour package and you want a bunch of
tutorials you can actually put this
online and somebody can play with the
code type thing okay i'm going to show
you one more example which actually I I
really like the same here so it's a
Google visualization so google voice is
a package that helps create google
visualizations and i'm going to create a
motion chart
okay so so you see that motion chart got
created line and so you can kind of use
these interactive slides to for
tutorials and maybe a couple of other
kind of applications as well okay now
not a kind of interactive slide okay is
so this actually is a shiny app so shiny
is one of the new packages are packages
that allow you to easily create reactive
programming models okay so this is
actually a ggplot graph which can be
controlled with the with the controls
that you see on the on the left side so
I can essentially change the the
coloring of the points so if i chose vs
you see that the the colors change the
points are colored based upon the
variable i choose similarly i can change
the x-axis here let's say a 50 x axis
here you can see that so it's a lot of
react so it's like reactor changes
happening okay i'll show you the core
code for this but i want to get through
the kind of interactivity so this is
another form of interactivity which is
this is purely ah ok so the controls are
are the plot is on and in the background
Chinese letting this length is doing
doing the essential so that our can talk
to the browser and do what it what it
does ok now another for interactivity is
a interactive charts ok so the ggplot2
graphic that you see is still a static
graph all right Evan you can't you can
do it's a sodding traffic on interact
with the craft so another example I want
to talk about and this is based on
another package that I will be
describing in more detail is our charts
and I have an example here which
actually creates an arch our plot in the
browser ok so and you can see that it's
actually being created and I'm not kind
of playing any games here ok hopefully
it should get ok so so you see here that
this arc would actually generated the
graph on the site let me let me change a
couple of things
I want to make it smaller so that it
fits in so this graph from the light
that you see is an interactive
visualization it's built using nvd 3
which is which is a light ready written
on top of d3 ok and i wrote a package
called our charts on top of anything ok
so i don't know anything about d3 all
that I've done is created in fact all
the work that I'm doing actually is
creating wrappers or top of rappers and
mathematics ok so none of this is I mean
truly original all all the credit goes
to the people who built the other really
cool boots now this one you can actually
interact with you can you can stack them
you can can change it you can change the
type of chart multipower let me just go
with horizontal chart here so now you
have a multi by horizontal sorry ok so
in this case how what is happening is
essentially once i once i click the Run
button this our code is actually
spitting out javascript and the
javascript is creating that plot over ok
so this is a rather form of
interactivity and and why is this easier
basically a lot of the boilerplate of
envy d3 is taken care of by the on-court
that i have here which is why we are
code is a lot shorter this is our i
believe does a lot better job of
handling data and which is why the code
is a lot working sighs I leave you with
one more example of interactivity which
is a combination of the two okay so this
is actually a shiny controlled
JavaScript visualization okay so what
you see on the on the left that's the
control side I basically have chosen
gender here this is again the same data
set so if i switch from male to female
you see that a slightly different graph
gets generate okay now i'm going to try
something
which may or may not work so let me go
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
interactively add so this is the part of
the code that generated that particular
graphic ok so I I can't I won't be able
to spend too much time I like staying
the course but I'll just explain the
part with relevant so what I'm going to
do now is I'm going to add another
control to the graph ok and so this time
around I am going to add the type of
graph ok so I'm just going to call it
tight then you type the whole thing that
I will speak
okay so what this does this is the UI
side effects of this select input
statement essentially creates a control
that will give you a drop-down menu with
multi bar chart and multi path
horizontal chart as the options okay and
shiny essentially will throw this into a
variable called input dollar type which
can then be accessed by the server side
okay so right now what I've done is I've
just written the client side you I ok
I'm now going to go on to the server
side part so let me just show sidebar so
the server side app is right here okay
and if you can see this is the code that
generated the graphic so all what I'm
going to do here is instead of type
equals multipath chart I'm going to put
in put dollar time okay so essentially
and shiny essentially takes care of all
the calculations the background so
whenever I change type shiny will
trigger this mechanism okay so now let
me just press save if everything works
and i do or okay didn't work i need to
figure out why didn't work
okay yeah that's a good idea
I know I know the source of the problem
so let me just quickly resolve that
because when I practiced the same thing
happened something to do with the
cashing out here so i just have to
remove the case and then it should be
fine no next door
anyway I that particular part network so
but you get never as you get a picture
as how you can kind of control the
different charts using so I've shown you
for different types of interactivity
here and now just like to summarize and
then move the code side so this is an
interactivity wave javascript is I mean
it's finally JavaScript this is an
example where our code is actually being
run this is an example where are
improving our again and the final
example that I showed you here was
something way our was used to being
control the controls and then once you
created the visualization it was an
interactive JavaScript please traffic
okay so let me let me show you the sum
of the code out here and quickly just
just take you through some of it so so
this is the interactive slide that you
saw okay so you saw and interactive
slide that we ggplot2 nothing and if you
look at the code carefully there are
only a few differences from what you
would have done if you had written it as
a as a regular little talk okay so a
couple of things so the and interactive
that you see here is telling so I
defying in this particular slide should
be taken through the interactive layout
okay an interactive layout has already
be built to kind of take care of all the
HTML or the nice buttons and all that
stuff so I don't have to touch it again
and the first coach UMP is just taking
care of a couple of I would say
boilerplate kind of things and the final
thing with the core charm that you see
here okay they require ggplot2 part I
just mark it as an interactive code
chunk and once you do that it renders it
as an interactive as an interactive
element okay so this is again very
useful for tutorials and other kinds of
other kinds of things okay i will show
you one more example and this example
also i had a little bit of difficulty
sometimes but hopefully
it's the Sun should work
so for all those out here using Python I
wasn't able to figure out a way to start
the static server with our it's a lot
more difficult so I am using Python here
this video covers the basics of
simulation okay so this actually
lashline next dress was used in the
thinnest course thank you my personal
simulation primarily and generate the
only last data sets that we could use to
illustrate introduced especially the
video a portable you you there three
different categories of simulation video
by talking on in this lighter although
more information can be found in the
previous lecture ask them if that's the
beginning progresses class I love this
wait for the next / emotions generates
random variables my molecular
distribution these functions start with
augus I think I said I'm legislators
Monica h2 region do it first Kirsty on
all i multiply visual your eyes so far
from our food represents the letters you
can do a similar thing with the vital
knowledge this is another exotic ikats
are get that sighs and I'm easily the
flight if I'm an affair with this whole
I looked amazing mr. whatever
possibility which is a here's the
bullwhip generalization it different and
scenarios would fly to fly is ten
different chords or flip just Egypt okay
so I need to go ahead and inspect
element of a browser so you see every
time I actually advance the slide you
see that it's spitting all over you
might want to the day all right so it's
actually what is doing is it's taking
its taking the timing of each slide into
account so if you if you record a
presentation using clarified ok at the
end now I am kind of not very good with
JavaScript so I couldn't figure out a
way to dump this directly profile but
right now the way it works is you create
the presentation you record it you copy
this into a JSON file and then once you
do that you just have to wait the
popcorn engine and it's going to be
give you this okay so to kind of
summarize some times where where I think
this will be very useful and very highly
applicable as you depend think is
combining the interactive code execution
with pop culture's able to create
interactive tutorials right where you
explain something and then you can also
make the video pass at the right times
people can execute the code practice and
do diversities okay so this is this is a
couple of examples that I had on on
interactivity with interactive documents
in tackling this i define the next thing
I want to talk about and I think I'll be
doing in time jet it hey so I'll I'll
kind of try to wrap this up quickly and
I want to keep people away on a on a
Monday evening so the next thing I want
to talk about is a specific form of
interactivity which is this actually
integral component of interactive
documents which is interactive
visualizations okay so I essentially
built a package called bar charts this
is a brand new website of the package
and essentially what our charts does is
again it gives the same philosophy is
clarified it takes a familiar interface
for our users which is usually a plot X
comma Y comma data set and then it
creates javascript-based visualizations
using multiple libraries and currently
it supports six or seven seven seven
different batteries i will show you a
couple of demos okay so let me start
with my first demo and this is something
which if you if you install our charts
you can do it yourself
so this was a tool that I built based
upon something that UV was the author of
knitter and Bill I just made it a little
bit so that i can use it for some of my
packages so what this actually does is
the what you see on the left hand side
is the coke is an R markdown document
and what you see on the right is the own
good okay so the reason I created this
is because I was kind of getting very
frustrated trying to work with shifting
between the browser and my my editor
okay so this allows me to kind of see
how the charts get created in the line
thousand okay and i will show you a
quick a couple of examples here so so
one of the libraries that supported by
by our charts is a polytron which is
actually very similarly digital onto
which you can recognize based only on a
syntax here so I'm just going to change
just one element of this dynamically to
see so you can see that it works yeah so
so I actually I just changed the
faceting off the plot and you see that
the flower change here and the nice
thing with JavaScript based Lars is that
you get a lot of features for free so
things like mouse over mouse click so
all those kind of things you get for
free and that's a feature of the Polish
art library out here so uh so our card
supports multiple libraries and each of
these actually is has its own set of
strengths and limitations it also
supports a mapping library which is
leaflet and that's that's going to be
the next demo that I'm going to be
showing you so I essentially use the
same approach to create a live a life
scenario of availability of city bikes
okay and that's going to be my next
amount here let me close this shiny
server
ok
so I'll show you the code behind this
but what this essentially does is it
basically takes data from City bikes and
essentially runs it through our to
calculate what is the availability of
bikes is each of these locations and
then color-coded based on availability
so all the red locations over here are
locations where the percentage of bikes
as a total capacity available is very
low click on it to get more details so
if we click on it so example this is
Broadway invest 49 street no bikes
available total docks ft 1 okay now this
application is actually pretty
straightforward to create using shiny
and our charts I'm just going to open
the code so that I will just point out a
couple of things that are interesting
there so it's actually the three parts
to the code and I not going to go into
much detail so the first part of the
code the gate data function here as you
can see both data from citi bike okay
and essentially it adds a bunch of feels
so it's add adds a color based upon the
status of the particular station it adds
a pop up so which you kind of see and
that's pretty much all it does ok now
the plotting part of the function that
you see you so this is essentially a
plot based upon our charts so what it
does is it creates a new instance of
leaflet leaf lettuce is one of the
libraries and insurance supports and
pretty much all the rest of the court
essentially won the second line here
sets a particular map type ok so you can
see you can see what happens if I change
that so I know let me just change this
to stamen watercolor ok and I need
clothes tiny server because shiny
doesn't refresh
the global things or we just run it
again so now you see you can get the
same map but it's essentially using a
slightly different map provided okay so
so those parts of the code essentially
allow you to do that and the rest of the
code is a lil bit of JavaScript in it
but I'm not going to go into details
details of that okay so this is another
cool example of what you can do with
with our and shiny and this is actually
the server side of the code and so what
it does is it fake it fetches data every
every 10 minutes and essentially renders
the map using a function that I have in
our charts called in a map and and you
can you can change the frequency I don't
want to ping the city server like every
every minute you want them to come back
and complain so right now it's every 10
minutes and this is the the server side
the UI side is even simpler pretty much
this is this is only thing on the other
side map output is a function from our
charts and it basically just puts the
entire map okay I'll show you one more
interactive visualization which one this
yeah this is inaudible online i'm going
to put so all these are scattered across
multiple repositories what i'm going to
be doing is I'm going to putting all of
them together in one typo I'll send out
the link to you so that people can play
around and this one is also oddly enough
that's right this was also one glimmer
or which is an ass to do supported
Chinese my hackers we do the farming my
hacker treat the waves oh yeah yeah
that's right okay so i'm going to show
you one other example and this is this
an example that I i really like let me
just make sure to find it
so like many of you I I follow sports of
course for I follow was cricket which
has a lot of data but I wouldn't be able
to get my hands on a on a good good said
so this is an example of creating what
occurred bump charts the palm chart
essentially plots the progression of a
team through the entire season ok so
again the same strategy I get data so
I'm going on each of these commands here
I've done some data manipulations I mean
this is and this you can do in any
language I just chose our and I'm going
to get the bomb chart data I'll move on
to the plotting part of the code which i
think is the is the one that's
interesting thing so let's first execute
everything we will see how the output
looks and then i will discuss be
coordinated
so this is a bunch are this is actually
created using Rick shop which is a
library built on top of d3 and again our
chart is built on top of that nice thing
is that you get a lot of functionality
for free i mean the rickshaw guys have
done an amazing job so let's say I want
to look at Chelsea you can just click on
Chelsea and you pretty much you have
Chelsea isolated here you see how the
position of Chelsea has changed over
over the season okay you can also play
around with the slider at the bottom if
you if you if you want to kind of focus
on any particular part of the season the
nice thing is all these features kind of
comes from free when you work with a
really mature JavaScript library and why
why is it kind of interesting to combine
it with our and this is actually my
video on and I home is that our makes it
easy to make these plots reusable it is
our is very good with me so i'm going to
show you the same plot created for the
spanish me and once i got these
functions creating that plot was just
like another bunch of lines okay so
we're going to do that right now okay so
i already have the code here i'm just
going to comment it out
so you can see that I am just picking up
data from the side football theta only
reason I'm doing that is my data
manipulation code is built to the data
form and supplied by that website but as
you can see you can easily convert it
into like other data formats as well so
I'm going to run the same code out here
and you will see if everything goes well
at the end you should see a
visualization heavy Spanish
so I mean you see the teams out here so
this is Barcelona and then you have real
madrid and so what you create so the
biggest advantage of this approach is
that what you create a plant once it
becomes reusable you can just change the
underlying data and you can produce very
interesting visualizations okay so i
thought the final couple of points our i
really wanna climb hope is is that
interactive documents the reason why and
tractor documents are easy with with our
own with eccentric languages any happy
that is good at handling data and can
really make data needed a usable it's
easy to kind of fit it in with like a
javascript front end and big in raggedly
come into the picture okay I'm going to
do one last example then I'm going to
open up the floor for questions I know
it's a lot of topics covered i wanted to
kind of make sure that I cover cover a
good breath to give you a good feel for
the things that are possible okay and I
if you have questions some people than
having to take it so the final demo hard
actually take you through is
so this is actually the silly thing if
you think about it if you can create a
web page you can create a ransom right
is just a moving that goes on so I'm
actually going to create so the slide if
I website this is a slide if I website
out here okay so you can see the various
parts of it I'm going to try to create
the same website with all the car and
you can see there is no HTML in any of
these any of these folders okay but the
no HTML in the root folder I'm going to
run it through a command which for the
lack of innovative aiming on my part I
just called it blog if I and so what log
if I does is basically goes to all the
armor down documents and creates creates
a slight length okay it's a HTML page
for each of them okay and of course
there's a couple of drinking as well
with mint with nav bars and stuff like
that ok so I'm going to change the and
open this
little bit of styling in the browser
that's kind of carnage idol re but
otherwise you can see you can see that
the exact same slide the website got
generated with with sliding so so the
part I want to kind of plug whom here is
that so once once you can produce like
one page right you can produce a website
which is why i said you can essentially
make documents of the web you can you
can write your content in in simple are
marked down and then you can let a lot
of the background will be taken care of
by javascript CSS and slightest i
essentially provides this mechanism and
does things in the background that leads
these days okay so that's actually what
I have what I have yet I have more
examples but I think it will be good to
get any questions since I don't want to
exceed be on later so if you have
questions feel free to ask me
we're doing a few questions grandma you
guys want two questions for sick bank
will do that and we have one more
thinner raffle away I'm almost stick
around it's in such as a stick around
fast a lot of your questions first
question I will you'll repeat the
question yeah yep they're most involve
our apush i have is methods are so your
question is who any of the methods don't
require yes sir okay so if you issue if
I go out with some impact a slice that I
show you right the if you look at the
part let me just see if I have those
slides open yeah
okay so some of those examples those all
examples where r generates JavaScript
selects of all those interactive
visualizations that you saw those don't
require r300 because it's actually what
it what the awkward is doing is it's
creating it's writing jumps into into
the dog and what do you observe certain
document essentially they attack when he
comes straight from the jump if the only
part of the interactivity which
currently requires an our server is all
the shiny parts where you have actually
done artwork okay but the song ways to
bypass that because shiny uses reactive
programming model you can get that with
other jobs in place I'm very slight
angularjs and a couple of other things
and so then only thing you need in
addition is is the service for logan cpu
which allows you to kind of grew post
requests to a server and kind of that
runs are so then you know really the
shine so we propose request that i will
see a sign the dependencies i will play
out with a little bit but my large jobs
that is not happy
okay so mustache actually is a very very
general in planning framework okay and
actually it has implementations in
multiple languages so JavaScript it has
a limitation in our Python and Ruby
pretty much every language has an
implementation just a templating
framework it's just writing HTML in a
way with placeholders okay and our has a
library called this curve which handles
the mustache perfect so does that answer
your question yes
ok so those of you who don't and special
there is a Champions Trophy that's going
on a turkey where the nearest to cricket
tournament and especially which teams
will win the tournament and I'm fine my
money is in India but they suffered is
hundred was on any other questions yeah
sly
that
yes yes you can I'll show you a couple
of examples of these are done on servers
let me just give me quick
so for example this presentation is on
line is on a regular server that doesn't
run are okay and everything everything
on here I mean you any of anybody who
can access the website and say they
don't mean odd on their computer to view
these slides okay so does that this is
not shine do not shiny you need a shiny
serve and and that's also open source
and you can actually you can install
shiny silver and there are some there is
a our studio has a free instance
available right now so if you need
interactivity where you need are
actively run code then you need shiny
but if you're choosing to do
interactivity to the other Road which is
our JavaScript then it's like a one-way
street okay and so all the
visualizations are showed you without
the controls essentially they're all
they can be done without a shiny self
and as I explained to him you can take
out the shining dependency completely if
you're able to manipulate the JavaScript
directly from Charles okay but I do it
without which is what I'm come yeah
all right the hard way back is
regression to be to be honest I I'm
still amazed that all this works because
if you can look in the background there
are a zillion javascript file is nine ok
so so so the other big question is so
the way I do most of the development is
I kind of play out with sick single
pieces and then i can combine the pieces
and try to see if it works a white my
way of the bar i guess is not a rigorous
if it works it works and that's
essentially how i have i kinda stayed
but at some point i think i like to talk
to people who were javascript to see how
some some of the buses features can be
built in but i don't know any rigorous
debugging which i'm not about a software
developer buying my profession so this
is something that i just picked up yeah
what's the advantage of having our third
as opposed to and the horse riding java
synthetic so i think the biggest so okay
so let me go back to the kinds of
interactivity that i showed you right so
so one kind of interactivity was the
interactive visualizations where the
JavaScript kind of handle everything but
if you require a step where where a user
action will require our code to trigger
something else again okay yeah so the
example of the city in the city bike
example that I that I just sure let me
actually fill up the online version of
that
actually this application is not a good
example luck maybe so so in this case I
need any harm because every 10 minutes
it takes the later from city's website
it adds the colors in the require ok and
then space another set of creation ok
now in this pretty good example you
don't need you don't need our if you're
comfortable JavaScript because honestly
you can read the data from cities and
you could do the rate of crossing the
charles there so it's not like this
cannot be done but because our makes it
easy to process data right having an
hour suburb essentially allows you to
use the power of art for doing the data
processing so the I think anti
depression is the advantage using in our
server is that a lot of rate of crossing
can be happen easily and you don't have
to write a verbose JavaScript to get the
same benefits okay so for example you
can if you want to do a regression of
some kind I mean you can essentially
drum the same the code the data you
collect you can run the regression and
you can post it back to this page it
shows some kind of availability versus
some other variable right you can do the
same thing in JavaScript but our has
built-in routines for it any other
questions
so I know I've talked about a lot of
things the websites are under active
development documentation is also
underway so if you have any fear ? and
how so these post questions or any
feedback that you have and my whole idea
is to make things really simple to
create interactive documents and this
was essentially to give you a flavor of
water thing is set or boss okay thanks